la primera vuelta de las legislativas
francesas del domingo se vio
ensombrecida por el escaso entusiasmo de
los votantes con una tasa de abstención
del 50 y 2.3 por ciento lo que significa
que uno de cada dos franceses decidió no
votar por nuestro primer deber colectivo
es reducir la abstención seguiremos
trabajando en ello reformando nuestras
instituciones y modernizando el diálogo
con el conjunto de la sociedad
a todos los que se han abstenido quiero
decirles esta noche que crean en la
fuerza de su voto y que hagan oír su voz
el próximo año ninguna porción el índice
de abstención ha batido un récord por
esta primera vuelta de las elecciones
legislativas es el más bajo desde que se
instauró en la actual quinta república
francesa en
1958 según los politólogos esta baja
participación se debe a la desilusión de
los votantes franceses hacia los
políticos a no sentirse representados
por los candidatos también podría
deberse al calendario electoral francés
ya que las elecciones parlamentarias se
celebran apenas unas semanas después de
las presidenciales y es difícil volver a
captar el ínter el público tras una
intensa campaña nacional
esta desconexión típica preocupante y
ahora estructural muestra hasta qué
punto nuestro sistema electoral
antidemocrático requiere una reforma
que forme la coalición de izquierda
nubes y la ultraderechista agrupación
nacional tienen ahora una semana para
movilizar a los abstencionistas
históricamente desde 2002 la afluencia a
los colegios electorales para la segunda
vuelta de las legislativas es aún menor
con un récord de abstención en 2017 del
50 y 7.4 por ciento